oh okay well we're four minutes into
after six o'clock
and uh we're all here
well rob
are we all here are are you really here
right because i feel like you're um do i
look it
you look you know
listen buddy
you don't ever i've never seen you look
uh
like
the kind of tired where you look
terrible but i mean i could just tell by
the facial expressions you're making the
the the amount that you're blinking
uh that you're struggling right now
i'm struggling yeah and it's hard to see
your friend struggle it's tough
i don't like it
um why don't you tell everybody what you
were just why don't you tell everybody
what you were just doing and why it was
so important and uh
and uh let's just
you know let's get into it
yeah
i'd like to know i i haven't talked to
you since you were over there so i'd
like to know
it's 6am here well it's actually 605
in the morning um
charlie's not here
but uh but we're here
yeah and uh i'm a little foggy
because i just got back from europe
um
doing a thing in europe
and um
oh charlie's chrome is out of date he's
got all sorts of he's replacing it
oh yeah um that's okay i just got back
from europe and we have a lot going on
and then
it's it's six a.m and uh i'm just a
little out of it
but i'll snap to it do you want to do
you want to tell us what you were doing
over there in uh europa
yeah i was in wales
i was in london i was in wales
and uh i was watching football watching
football
soccer here in the united states and um
and then uh i did actually i did the i
did the podcast last week you i didn't
we missed you
i thank you i i saw that um
you know it was interesting because i i
saw you guys trying to go into a thing
where you were uh you know gonna give me
[ __ ] for not being there because i
couldn't be there uh but you know
there's just not that much [ __ ] you can
really talk about me i i you were trying
you were trying and i i appreciate that
because that would have been very funny
but then i think you very quickly
realized like
we love this guy there's there's nothing
we can say that bad about him really um
you know
i might have cut that glenn i might have
just cut that
out caught all that
i'm going to disable my videos i can't
disable your video this is a video
podcast i just feel very self-conscious
i feel like there's a camera pointed
right in my face i'll get past it i'll
get past it i'm these these are all
champagne problems i'm not i'm not
really complaining i just i feel like
[ __ ]
and um
you know i'm gonna snap out of it glenn
you know me i could i can come into a
room and feel real bad but then i can i
could snap through it
listen i've i i i
you've always been good at that so much
better at that than me sometimes it
takes me
hours
hours to warm up and uh
and uh you know
snap out of it so to speak when i'm when
i'm in the kind of place that you're in
right now you know what people probably
love to hear they they turn on their
podca they turn on the podcast because
they want to they're driving to work and
it's 6am where they are and they're like
they want to hear they want to hear tv
stars moaning they want to hear people
who fly back from europe just
complaining right yeah yeah that's the
kind of [ __ ] that'll snap me out of it
oh boy but i have just a little bit of
perspective and i'm like
you know
shut up i just yeah you're like i just
i'm just i'm i'm tired i just got back
from europe where i was watching the
football team that i own
uh play and you know and the first class
i gotta look
you know i don't want to complain here
but
you know it's just not first class it's
just not the same as private you know
it's great it's great you know and i had
my i had my own pod but it was one of
those pods in the middle where you're
right next to somebody else's pod
you know what i mean it's you want to be
on the pods on the side where you're
just totally alone and isolated you know
and i had a pod and it was next to a guy
and i could hear him
breathing and it just i don't know you
guys the flight attendant kept asking me
do you want something is there something
else we can bring you sir and i'm like
leave me alone well also but wait could
you grab me a champagne i mean that'd be
great yes yes literally champagne
problems can i get you some more
champagne and i'm like you're making
this a problem
you keep bothering me i'm trying to
relax with my well hang on a second yes
i do want more i'm just saying don't
every five seconds be
well i'm not saying don't check on me
definitely check on me i mean i want to
make sure that the glass is at least
half full but if it's not if it's more
than half full then maybe just give it a
sec okay
it's always half empty it's always half
empty that's i think that's is that is
that what we're getting to
that is what we're getting anyway
can you see me can people see and hear
me yes we can see we can see you now
charlie hi what the [ __ ] happened i went
to
do the same old same old and it goes you
got to use a newer
google chrome
so i uploaded the thing off the [ __ ]
internet
and now my charlie we spent the first 12
minutes complaining
and um and then realizing that the
audience well i'll tell you something
completely did you want some extra
complaints yeah
throw in some of your complaints i i
think it's great
i can barely see you guys why did you
update it to like
if you want we can update it and make it
worse work your computer yeah we've
we've up we've ma
and and
we've made it worse um
yeah this is i i by the way i i'm loving
this because i feel like i'm always the
one who's like tired in a bad mood and
[Music]
because i get up early anyway but i i
generally don't get up and then get on
the camera and i think that's my
it's a source it doesn't matter do you
resent it a little bit do you resent it
come on let's say it's okay hey guys
people want to hear about this stuff
they do you know no you know what they
want to hear about because it's [ __ ]
hilarious the gang gets whacked yeah
since i just did boom eyes i got to
throw a quick shout out to my buddy greg
weiner who uh plays bingo in the episode
one of my closest friends for a very
long time we we uh we're roommates
together in miami florida
for a short period of time and i just
absolutely love that guy and i miss him
and i think he's great in the episode uh
the eyes bit speaking of boom eyes i
believe that was a bit we came up with
on the day i don't think that was
something that was in the script i think
that was something that we've just
realized on the day would be funny i
don't know the casting of bingo
it was like the was the first time where
we really thought well we're in season
three
and we see all these other shows we see
all these other shows and they seem to
be able to
get
stars on them to do just quick cameos
and we thought that'd be cool um
i guess are people watching the show
it's hard to tell there's no social
media we don't really we don't really
know we don't trust the ratings that are
being given to us because they're being
used as pieces of information to
leverage against us during our
negotiations so so so are people
watching the show i don't know well
let's make some offers to some stars and
see you know we have this funny
character named bingo wait wait can i
can i do do you remember who we offered
it to first
because i think i remember i think i
remember i did let's see if we all
remember i do okay should we write it
was a sean penn it was a champagne yeah
i think you would chant that yeah yeah
yeah
let's start with sean penn yeah we're
going down to greg weiner
do you remember the progression i
remember the progression
no i don't remember the progression i
just remember i was going to sean penn
and i do remember thinking like he might
do it i mean danny's on the show he
might do it he might have done it you
know here's the thing it might not have
ever even gotten to him
you know it's like the thing where you
reach out to his reps and they're like
no he's not going to do uh one scene on
a basic cable show like the only way to
get to a guy like that is like a friend
has to call a friend like danny we
didn't have to do it we did
try to reach out to him yeah yeah we did
we did okay yeah yeah and even then i
don't blame him he's like uh he's like
in [ __ ]
you know haiti saving people's lives but
it was around the time that entourage
was on and people were doing entourage
left and right now that's a show about
the entertainment industry nevertheless
they did it
so we didn't get sean penn
and the date was looming and it was it
was getting close but we thought okay
how about okay
let's go to somebody else who who would
be
um not a person necessarily of note or
of name but somebody you've seen in
a lot of movies and he's a great actor
and we have a personal connection to him
and he would be great
he's not exactly sean penn but he's
fantastic and do you know who that
person was
sorry louis guzman
we offered it to louis guzman yeah
because i was i was buddies with louie
so i just texted him
and louie was like
more willing to do it and it was just a
schedule thing and then
he just couldn't do it that's right but
louis might is on it like if he was in
town and and had louis would have been
amazing
he would have been amazing
i would love that guy yeah why are we
not on the show no it's crazy that we
have well now but now we're in a
position where people say hey i love
sonny can can can we can i do i'd love
to do an episode and then we think about
it we talk about it and then we maybe
say yeah greg
are you we're shooting at this period
are you available nah man i'm just not
available and it just never works ever
ever yeah
but it's also yeah it's also there's
also rarely ever a guest star role on
our show that would be worthy of those
people's time right so i
you know i think of some of those people
and i'm like i want to put them on the
show but i want to put them in something
that's like not just you know us
like the usual guest star which is us
being insane
and uh you know the person sitting
across from us very grounded and real
like what is happening you know well
literally saying i will also say i do
think maybe it was a blessing in
disguise where from a creative
standpoint where you know
when you have your pick
and anyone who's anyone can play the guy
working out of a garage named bingo
right
you know
it becomes so top-heavy in a way where
it can pull the audience out or suddenly
they're like wait holy [ __ ] that's that
guy that's sean penn that's sean pam
what is he doing on this show it was
it's always been fun to me to mostly
populate the show with
people you've either never seen or or or
don't have preconceived notions of you
know
yeah
this was the only
the only season really where we had so
many characters who played real
characters like those gangsters are
almost like cartoon
cartoon characters they're so funny
but we very rarely do that so funny
yeah do you guys remember casting those
guys um how you went about the usual way
uh i i think we look i think we just
looked at casting right guys i mean we
didn't know who those guys were
um i think we just cast who we found to
be the funniest in their auditions and
then it was really interesting because i
don't think the three of them knew each
other
yet
they instantly
became
like
this like trio of guys like they were
they were chat
i believe is the word
paisan
is the word
oh okay yeah you guys keep talking i'm
gonna be right or not i'm gonna be right
back
okay all right i don't think those guys
knew each other but they they came
together and it was almost like they
were a like a comedy trio like almost
instantly
look at this [ __ ] guy
holy [ __ ]
wow that's a good move that's some
that's some that's some uh that's a good
move yeah
you know it's funny
i thought about doing that same bit
i was like if i had some really big
mobster glasses and i don't i was like
but if i had big like kind of mobster
glasses i would wear them
yeah
there's less of a gangster thing and
more of i'm just looking at myself in
this camera and i feel like i want to
bash my my own head into the into the
wall so
oh wow let's talk about that let's talk
about that
this is sort of me hiding what do you
think you think you look puffy
you look puffy
i love you rob you're handsome
you're talented
you're smarter forget about it hey
hey forget about your stupid water face
i forgot about it over here so this for
any of the creeps out there i'm wearing
sunglasses now and as i'm looking at it
now it truly is the this was a look
adopted by gangsters in the 30s and the
40s and the 50s and when they got called
in front of congressional
hearings they would they would get
called there's this one famous
famous guy named joey gallo crazy joe
gallo and he got called before congress
to to testify in the senate and he wore
these glasses like that almost look
exactly like this now what what sells
gangster more than going into [ __ ]
testifying in front of the senate and
not taking your sunglasses off and like
i think he had like a toothpick and he
was like picking
picking his teeth and putting on a show
yeah i mean that was the that's the most
amazing thing about those heroes is the
like defiant sarcasm yeah you're on it
like
never heard of a gangster laughs
the whole room like kind of chuckles a
little bit and then they're like like
sir please take these proceedings
seriously like you know uh
what line of work are you in
construction
please say it with less sarcasm
a little less sarcasm
like what yeah
they
i mean just open open defiance and then
yeah
because why not
what's the worst case scenario oh wait
jail forever
oh you know you're getting
yeah yeah yeah sir why are you wearing
the sunglasses it's so bright with the
glare off your pearly white skin
why is it that
there's like a
charm to it well because they're they're
living outside of social media so it's
it's kind of it's kind of exciting to
get it yeah from being on the outside
and looking in yeah we love we love
we love uh rebellious behavior we love
rebels and we love any sort of form of
rebellion
it's baked into our culture here in
america you know to to uh to like rebels
and like you know
yeah everybody wants to whack somebody
off and get away with it right
absolutely absolutely that's yeah we're
going right for that cheap joke in that
episode
that's that's a joke that we i don't
think would
make any more like uh you know just
talking about whacking us off
so stupid so stupid but funny
but funny you know is this good lighting
that's fresh morning sun
i'm fresh my coffee maybe i'll grab some
sunglasses too because i actually need
them
i'm just i'm just looping podcasts just
podcasts is off the rails this one
we're gonna we're gonna have to get this
we're gonna have to whack this podcast
um since everybody's getting up i'm
gonna check to see who's knocking on my
door okay
i'm gonna leave this part in the podcast
where none of you are here just
there we go
oh he's a foggy as hell he's a foggy as
[ __ ]
now do you think that the do you think
that the sunglasses thing was a uh was a
def uh defiance thing or was it like a
recognition that uh
okay everybody's gone i'm talking i'm
here i'm here i i i want the option to
put on my sunglasses too
what do you mean
i can't even [ __ ] see you now yeah he
turned off all the lights what is
took my happening off but i turned all
the lights off and i closed the shades
but the thing is is like the original
thing where we could see your face your
regular face was the best look and then
you put on sunglasses and a hat and it
actually made
i would argue you looked worse it just
looked weird
and now you just
now you look like you're in a [ __ ] uh
found footage which project yeah you
look like you're in the [ __ ] blair
witch project
i'm getting blair witch five for sure
turn the lights on forget about it
rob has like the most confidence of
anybody but then when he doesn't he goes
hard in the opposite direction like then
he has none at all it's very strange
right
well he oscillates between extremes
doesn't it yeah that's true
glenn do you think if i'd
my grandpa kept his last name del giorno
i could have gotten cast in gangster
movies or i just looked too like irish
and they would have been like nah his
name's still journaling he doesn't have
that doesn't have a stereotype it
doesn't look enough
the part
i mean you don't yeah you don't you
don't look you you don't look italian
for what
everyone else who got in there well how
how much how much are you italian like
what how many likes robert de niro a
quarter
wait daniel's a quarter italian quarter
yeah i have the same exact like if you
look up
oh he has like the english and italian
and irish and it's the same like spread
izzy
oh but he looks italian as hell
i i i never knew that you know who's my
favorite italian actor
talking about gangster movies
roberto benini
i could watch roberto benite do anything
he only did the one movie didn't he i
mean i said he did about 500 italian
movies yeah exactly like he could find
him
yeah he did a couple like um
he did um oh christ yeah maybe we do
have to move this podcast later jim
jarmisch
uh jim jarvis moved down by law he's
really funny that
remember when we started the episode
complaining about [ __ ]
can't hear him at all it's all dead he's
gone right
is this crazy this is crazy we should
just
[Music]
hey everybody it's time to subsidize
megan's rent again apparently she's
broke overseas not gonna make it back to
the states
i put together a very sufficient uk
travel fund but i didn't convert it to
pounds
sorry meg your dollars are only as
valuable as the queen
decrees
right so who's gonna float you the cash
this time how are you gonna get it well
this time it's our friends at liquid iv
who are fueling life's adventures with
their delicious and super efficient
electrolyte delivery powder guys did you
know there's a lot of research coming
out that staying hydrated is actually
good for your health
wait a second staying hydrated is good
tell me more well there are two times
that i find liquid iv particularly
helpful the first
is before or after a workout i got three
times the amount of electrolytes as
traditional sports drinks so it gives me
that lift and i think it tastes way
better too the other is
honestly the other time is when i'm
hungover it really does work right if
i'm hungry manhattan after your gigantic
manhattan you're going to want to use
that liquid of iv too right uh so go
grab liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquidive.com and use the code sunny
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you use the promo code sunny
at
liquidive.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidive.com promo code sunny
all right uh those three guys like uh
first of all
the guy who played lefty
who in the second episode not the first
episode was like he's got very beautiful
hands
what was his name ah shoot i don't
remember his name but he
is so he had this delivery that was felt
so he just felt he feels like a very
he feels like a very real person like it
doesn't seem it weirdly doesn't feel
like he's acting to me
it seems like a yeah it was so relaxing
natural so relaxed and so natural and i
remember us kind of leaning in to being
like what is he what is he doing and
giving him more and more as we went you
know like i don't think he had as much
scripted and then being like hey you
know can can we actually give that to
this guy and have him say the thing like
and maybe use
you know if you know we may or may not
you know his rhythm his rhythm in that
little speech that he gives about fri
friday is just so funny you know ending
it like with a little beat and then
and that's friday
and that's right and that's fine it
might have been those guys decision to
be eating the sandwiches like his like
his decision to come walk around no i
think that was a
roselle i think that was a roselle thing
i think it was like yeah yeah these guys
should just always be eating like lunch
meats deli sandwiches and lunch meats
like just a total stair it's just the
most
stereotypical possible thing
i constantly be eating [ __ ] deli
meats
i very much enjoyed the uh the tango and
cash bit at the at the beginning um
let's move it's just uh
just a great uh it's just it just just
made me laugh although i will say from a
technical standpoint rob um
if i had it to do all over again
and this is very technical i would have
let you get out a little bit more of
kurt russell's name before cutting you
off
you know what
i just think it would have been just a
just a hair funnier like two percent
funnier if i just heard a little bit for
those who and for those who don't know
who started tango and cash you've got to
get the spoon the specifics are
important
but i i like how we um we just got away
from
we would every episode we would sort of
reset and then
show in the cold open what the problem
was
so we would we would suggest that hey we
need money right isn't isn't that kind
of what we're going for it's like okay
so we're saying we need money to fix
something
yeah uh yeah and then all of a sudden
this opportunity for money comes into
the bar um which we just
got rid of i guess pretty quickly after
that where we realized the audience just
it doesn't doesn't care that we need
money in this particular episode well in
some ways it
who doesn't want money right so it would
have been fine to have us just talking
about whatever the hell we wanted to
talk about and then have them come in
and be like look what we found like why
not
but i think we needed a couple seasons
to get there narratively right where so
the audience knows okay frank really
sports these guys and and like his whole
thing in this is like i'm done bailing
you out right fix your own damn lights
right right we were setting that up so
like
yeah and then by the time we got to the
fourth season we really didn't need to
lay any of that you know we the rules
were established frank has the money we
have no money we're back
it's also interesting to watch to to
watch frank be
sort of the the
the straight man the moral compass in
the episode the one who's like
you know what i mean like it's just it's
so funny to think how far that character
is coming he does eventually uh you know
become my pimp so i mean he he gets
there very quickly he gets there very
quickly
but it was that all that stuff is so
good
how about the how about the how about
the jockey how about that actually that
was great oh man i think i if i recall
correctly that was a standardized
practices note where he couldn't buster
couldn't do a line off your dick and and
he couldn't do a line off your [ __ ] but
he could do a line off your boner
yeah and let buster do a line off your
boner which was 10 times funnier well
it's always funnier when they put us in
a box and we got to come up with some
other
thing i had no recollection of picking
up the horse poop
what a stupid and fun joke it's like you
know you have a problem around
normally we'd use a shovel for that but
to each his own
jockey culture
a jockey culture in which they're all
just
partying and blowing rails and [ __ ]
each other is
i
fascinating i i it's it's a great joke because it's
not something that you associate with
jockeys at all it's like something we
just completely invented like
that they're just part of us
um
me confusing him with a lawn jockey is
fun lawn jackets are so messy well also
the idea that the idea that like you
know what a lawn jockey is but you
didn't know that jockeys were real you
just thought they were like lawn
ornaments
you didn't know jockeys were even a
thing you know what i mean like
um a miniature man on a horse
the way that frank convinces you to
become a pimp
[Applause]
about that actor the actor who plays the
the gigolo who who recruits me that guy
was so funny man
he's so funny i think he had done i
think he had done mostly soap operas at
that at up to that point like something
makes me think yeah he was like a a soap
actor
um and i don't know it's just another
guy that we i think just auditioned and
um but this is the concept that he pays
this guy
he well
he's going to give him 20 bucks and then
he just sniffs and gives him 10.
and then he says
yeah and then i love i love that we
stayed on that we made the choice to
stay on him and let him go fully back to
like putting the hair net on and
starting to wash the dishes you know
gives the guy like a little nod that
he's working it's just
do you remember who that security guard
is glenn the guy that kicks us up big
will oh yeah
the guy the guy that kicks us out
is uh is this guy named big will and he
i met him at gold's gym in venice beach
he was a trainer there but he's a
bodybuilder yep and man i mean
if anybody has seen pumping iron or is
into um bodybuilding at all
they know of of venice golds it's a
famous gem that arnold schwarzenegger
used to work out and they're still
i don't know at any given moment there's
15 to 20 bodybuilders in there working
out and will was
amongst amongst the biggest yes yeah
professional professional bodybuilders
who you know do what uh schwarzenegger
did like you know mister universes and
[ __ ] like that like
it's the uh what do they call it the
mecca of bodybuilding yeah and so i
remember the wardrobe department had
tried to so we wanted to have him in a
specific thing because there was other
security guards or whatever so it was
like a uniform and the wardrobe
department couldn't find clothes that
fit him so they had to they had to make
his clothes yeah yeah well let's not
leave out the fact that big will was
also your trainer for the creative time
at gold's too it's not just a guy that
you knew you trained with big will he
drank
that's what he did he was a he was a
trainer at goals
i wasn't necessarily going for his
physique but he was yeah he trained all
you know he trained in all all sorts of
different
body types i suppose
i mean the number of the the number of
years it takes to
pack on that much
uh mass
you know that's not just the kind of
mass that where you're ballooned up you
know and then the second you stop like
two months later you're back down you
know what i mean like the kind of mass
where you're just layering on like dry
meat it's called bulk
dirty bulk
a dirty bulk is when you put on weight
by any means necessary so
you're not you're not
you're not concerning yourself
now listen to me listen to me you put
i'm telling you you put on weight by any
means necessary you do whatever it
takes okay i don't care if you gotta go
to mcdonald's from sunrise or something
you go
that that's exactly what it means
necessarily well because
you got to kill a kid
do it
do it
drink it don't wait done
that is truly exactly what it means
where you because
you're in a restaurant you get up from
your table you see another table people
still haven't eaten you gobble down
there
you get it
you got it
i could do a whole episode on any means
necessary
frank and charlie feeling as though they
have to eat by any means that's it
that's an episode
hey
put it up on the
board that's how a thing goes
meg can you get that on a card meg can
you hear us let's get that on a card
[Music]
and our next sponsor is our friends over
at helix sleeve for when you're ready to
get off those toes and lay down for a
good night's rest oh you gotta love them
you gotta now that's been my experience
with helix they make the top of the line
mattress that
it's leaving me feeling more rested and
refreshed you know what i mean they have
a two minute sleep quiz on their website
that will match you with the exact right
mattress for your needs whether you're a
side or a back or a stomach sleeper or
even a plus side sleeper
yep and then they ship it right to your
door for no additional charge you have
100 days to try it out risk-free they'll
even pick it up if you don't love it but
guess what you're gonna love it creep
yeah i took the quiz it's short but
shockingly accurate it's kind of a
mattress matchmaker i was paired with
the perfect fit in under two minutes and
have been sleeping happily ever since
basically helix is the best and you yes
you should own one and lucky for you
helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com slash sunny
[Music]
let's catch the audience up um
i have an older computer that i like to
write on i just like the honestly the
feel of the keys they i think they can
take the brunt of my two-finger
hammering uh which is basically how i
it's amazing the amount of sunny uh
episodes that have been written like
you know like an old typewriter or
something uh i mean mary elizabeth makes
fun of me she's like are you trying to
break the computer
uh but i think i didn't break the
computer until i uploaded the most
recent version of google chrome and the
computer was like nope not doing it guy
and the whole thing sort of fell apart
but
here we are
trying to salvage what's left glenn
obviously can't be here because uh it's
not his day off from the movie he's
doing so he's working
uh but rob said he could be here and now
rob is two minutes late okay so i'm i'm
enjoying this
i'm enjoying it i remember when he said
i gave you i will never be like here he
is
i'm not late
just two minutes
rob
is wearing his best forget about it
shirt
that's pretty good did you do that
intentionally
you know what i had a shirt i have this
shirt in my closet
i've had it in there for about a year
and i keep you know you have those that
clothing and you think like one day i'm
gonna wear that and then i was doing a
little cleaning spring cleaning i'm
gonna get rid of a bunch of stuff in my
closet and i looked at that shirt and i
said no i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
wear that one day and caitlin said you
haven't worn it in a year
it's time to get it out of the closet
and go and i said
i'm gonna wear the shirt today what do
you think
um besides this shirt did you did you
bring your mic um to this recording or
while he sets up his mic i'll describe
the shirt to the audience so it's sort
of it's like a
bubble gum purple
um
that's great it has like like a white uh
white outline so like an outline around
the collar outline piping really yeah
it's sort of a funny idea which is like
like telling people like where the
things are in case you don't see the
collar we'll let you know the colors
right here uh and it has a bit of a
of a of a goomba kind of uh italian
flair to it which i personally like i
feel like you could keep a pack of
cigarettes in that front pocket and uh
but but could a mobster ever wear that
color though oh yeah yeah yeah that's
the thing about that yeah there's a lot
of lobsters can wear whatever they want
joyful colors
there was a there was a stewardess on
the flight who was talking so closely
into that little
sorry there was a flight attendant on
the on the um
genderless uh aircraft that we were uh
crossing the sky in no and the airplanes
are very clearly men they're just giant
dicks floating yeah i'm the flying penis
with wings and uh the flight attendant
um
was talking so closely into the thing
and with such a heavy accent that it was
completely you couldn't make a single
word of it so it really sounded like
that's a great imitation of everything
you hear at an airport everywhere you go
yeah that's true you're sitting waiting
at the in the jet way or waiting for the
flight just well the next time we'll
shut out the next one american airlines
yeah because they've said it a thousand
times and they're over it
i think they're talking about my time
going to see uh siegfried and roy with
mary elizabeth and we were in vegas and
it was like there
they said they're like this is our you
know 60 000th show
and they were so over it that you could
tell they were saying the things just
automatically
so they kind of said everything with a
sigh like
the power of magic the power of life the
power of magic is on all of us touch
sabers and then they would like touch
some sabers and they would kind of dance
across the stage like the power of the
power of a tiger is the power as in you
and me cat on touch saber
out loud
yeah they say it out loud touch sabers
yeah as if to be like
touch my [ __ ] saber roy or i swear to
god if you don't touch my saber
of course the cat the cats eventually
had enough of that [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah
yeah the big cat's had enough they had
enough
um rob cleaning out your closet was it a
um
did you get as much satisfaction out of
that as as
i do like when i throw stuff away it is
the greatest feeling ever i'm like oh
why did i have this thing for so long
yeah it's one of those quality of life
things that you know every time you i i
look in my closet and it's just a mess
and i'm thinking like one day i'm gonna
i'm gonna clean this i'm going to get
rid of half this stuff and then i i
don't and then over this past weekend i
decided i was just going to commit to it
and i did it and i feel great not as
good as meg would feel if she organized
her closet because i think she she
enjoys that very much
yes one time i did all my bathroom
drawers and i like put in little
dividers in them so like everything
within the drawer was like divided like
every bobby pin was like in its special
place and then i took a photo of it when
i was done because it was so
so satisfying
i believe you sent that photo to me i
probably did send it to you yeah
i recently did that as well i mean i was
throwing out like
a half a bottle of like some kind of
like uh antibiotic
i took and then stopped taking like in
2016 or something like why do i still
have this
i get busy
yeah busy
yeah
somebody celebrated a birthday this week
big news big news
megan do you like birthdays or do they
embarrass you uh i i generally like
birthdays um because
usually i feel pretty accomplished by
the time i like hit my birthday like it
always helps if i'm like starting a new
job right around my birthday and for
whatever reason for a lot of years
working in tv i would start a writer's
room in june so i was like oh it's like
this this thing of like oh you're you're
not the same as you were last year you
know there's something new happening in
your life
but this year was a little tough i
turned 38 and i was like
i don't know why i was i guess it's
because i finished a job
or like i'm coming to the end of mythic
quest
and then i was like traveling and i've
just been like eating and drinking all
the time and like not exercising or
doing anything so
it was kind of rough but
on my birthday i um
decided to jump rope for 38 minutes and
so i did that um and that made me feel
good but my uh calves are still so sore
that like when i go upstairs for 38
jumps
yeah we stop let's stop down on that for
a second that's psychotic what she just
described is psychotic she doesn't jump
rope on the regular she just decided out
of the blue on my 38th birthday i'm
going to jump rope for 38 minutes
anybody who's actually you know
notice that after one minute
it's extraordinary yeah yeah i i once
did it uh had like i was doing a workout
thing where it was like okay and then
the guy like sent me like hey do some
jump roping and one and i think that it
was like 10 minutes and 10 minutes of
straight jump roping was
awful yeah i think i was like nah i'm
done never again
um i it was really really brutal yeah i
have an ability to like
shut my brain off from my body in that
if my body is like this hurts i'm like i
don't have to listen to you and uh and
just like keep going
so i just did that for 38 minutes
yeah that's that's that's the mega i
know i mean that's that's psychotic she
has the ability to just bear down on
something she hasn't a goal and she will
she will accomplish that goal
regardless of the physics regardless of
the reality of her health regardless of
whatever might stand in her way so it
does not surprise me that she did 38
minutes
at all well it's an amazing feat
i tried to get on sunny for eight years
um and i and i did that so you know when
before you came on sunny
uh where did the gang get whacked uh
episodes rank in your enjoyment of the
show it was pretty it was pretty high up
there i mean my all-time favorite is the
gang gives frank an intervention
um so i'm really excited before we get
to that episode because i've probably
watched that episode like 50 times i
love that episode
we haven't discussed danny's friend
cha-cha yet right because we haven't
gotten to
the road but he makes an appearance in
this season
yes
and uh
he makes an appearance in the road trip
episode right
yeah isn't that season is that the next
season or is that this yeah he's the guy
that we buy the pair from that has the
sticker on that
um
and uh
cha-cha was like danny's old buddy who
he met him because he was tony danza's
fight promoter is that correct i think
that was what it was like yeah he was on
the fight
yeah and cha-cha definitely
was a connected guy
yeah
i i think we can taco i think we can
talk about this now because chacha's no
longer with us and i think it's okay but
i
and he's he was never
he was never open about it but it was i
think it was pretty clear that cha-cha
cha-cha was connected cha-cha knew some
people
i you know best guy he was the best he
was the best
he was the best he was a nice guy yeah
who knows too like
the thing the whole mafia thing like
i pretty much only know what i know from
movies and tv you know and uh maybe like
one book that i read but like
how much of it
is how much of it is an like actual
organization and how much of it is a is
like communities of people so that
there's overlap right where it's like um
you know like a community in let's say
staten island or jersey
where yes like
you know there's a group of very clearly
people who have are in these organized
crime families and then there's like
some people that it's like
maybe like cha-cha where it's like he
knows everyone he grew up with them
he might get a favor here and there but
he's not on the payroll
that would be the difference between
a made man and a connected guy
so the maid men are like the actual
members of the family
and there there used to be well i guess
i guess they still exist but the the ma
the five there's five major crime
families in new york and then and then
there's like all the ancillary
people that are around it and connected
to it like maybe drug dealers on the
streets or things like that but but the
maid members of the family
i think they're
depending on which family you were and
there was only a couple hundred of them
worldwide
oh wow rob probably knows more about
this because he reads more mafia books
than me but
i once read a book about the history of
the cosinostra cosa nostra who said that
right right and um
and how it started in sicily and there
was a lot of overlap between it just
being like a neighborhood thing because
basically what happened was sicily just
kept getting invaded by a bunch of
different countries and so they were
changing governments like all of the
time so the people that lived there
year round needed somebody that was like
consistent that they could turn to so
there were usually these people within
the town that were like you know they're
dons for instance they like oversaw the
things that they needed in their
community and so it really grew out of
like a need of consistency and having
you know that neighborhood like
connection
and so it's always been from that and
like i don't know what the translation
of that to new york was but that's
really where it came from and then
eventually it was like you know there
was lots of lemon groves in sicily which
made a lot of money and there were
people walking around being like god
it'd be a shame if these lemon groves
all burnt to the ground maybe you should
pay us to protect them
and uh there's a lot of that
i would hate to see it
but but according to cha-cha whenever
the mafia ever came up he would he would
always smirk and say what mafia there's
no mafia so he never talked about it
really but then he would tell these
crazy stories
crazy stories that were so
funny really um
i never heard any of like the violence
or anything like that it was more just
like crazy
he used to he he was in charge of
putting on the fireworks show for the
san genero festival on mulberry street
every year now now fireworks are illegal
in new york city private citizens can't
just set off fire fireworks so not only
did he have to transport them across
state lines but then he actually set
them off and one time he blew himself up
he he blew himself up on mulberry street
he said he was thrown
from the street almost onto somebody's
porch and into their living room
i had to go to the hospital
i bet
yeah he blew him up he was blown to
safety blown to safety blown over
someone's couch
yeah
you know danny though i remember being
specifically
not wanting to do anything that was
for him to stereotypical sort of mobster
italian just
wanting to say like hey i i i don't mind
you know doing an episode where we talk
about these characters that do exist um
and these sort of types but
also he didn't want to go down that
route so like when we were riding it you
know made sure that like it wasn't like
and then frank had some connections and
a connected guy like we avoid that
pretty much completely in that story
line
yeah
yeah well we didn't want to draw drawn
the the stereotype of like all italians
being gangsters or something i think
that he was very conscious of that which
i think was more of a more of an issue
back in the 60s 70s 80s like around that
godfather time when it was such a huge
part of the popular culture
and and i know that there was like the
the italian italian-american league that
was that was created in new york city to
sort of come back that there was a lot
of
prejudice against italians of course
that was started by a gangster
um who was trying to throw people off
the scent joe colombo who was the head
of the colombo crime family you know
what let's not talk about any of this
let's just call it
yeah yeah we're covered though all this
before we wind up you know
[ __ ] taking a cement bathroom i'm
actually italian too charlie did you
know that my my dad's side his brother
was born in italy
um and her name was ann delaulis and her
father's name was cesar delaulis and her
um
and his wife's name was conchetta de
apollonio
and they came over literally through
ellis island so we're good we're we're
totally we're good we can call us though
wow it was in their name to be lawless
yeah so uh yeah but but there were there
was prejudice against italians uh
because we were also like around world
war ii we were in a war with italy you
know so um
yeah that's why my grandfather
uh
no i guess was my grandfather that
officially changed his name from del
giorno today because it was like eh
let's just try to get rid of this
italian thing
but he couldn't change his nose and his
face but he did eventually through his
through children he just watered that
down and
homogenized into the yeah
where's glenn
should we discuss that he's not here i
mentioned it briefly before you popped
on but um
you know we are
we had technical difficulties what are
you gonna do about it you know
the main thing is that the show goes on
you know that someone can drive to work
and be entertained this is what this is
what is the point of it
so if the entertainment is that none of
us can get our damn computers to work
then that's what's funny
you know
[Laughter]
are you feeling better about your face
today
i feel better today yeah i feel like
well it's it's it's not it's not five
i was jet lagged and it was 5 40 in the
morning and people don't want to hear me
complain but um but i feel better today
yeah
it's better not to do it at five in the
morning for sure
yeah that's that was unless we're all
like in the same space at five in the
morning but
until we can all be together again
yes
yeah that would be fun but again i think
we've covered this too i like the idea
of somebody who's on their way to work
right now uh he's he's driving there to
work it's it's about 5 a.m and he's
hearing us complain about sitting in
front of a computer and talking
because it's too early
i left all that into
oh
was that was that from that episode
yeah from this episode yeah it's at the
beginning we're just complaining it
because glenn did that funny run about
champagne problems and you complaining
about your pod being next to somebody
else's pot on the plane
it's funny
by the way i i [ __ ] i i don't like
champagne so champagne alone is a
problem for me you know i agree
i
oh yeah the first couple times i had it
i was like wow this is refreshing and
sparkly and light and amazing and then i
was like
it's like
a cup of pure sugar you guys are wrong
it's delicious you like the champagne i
love it i think meg was drinking
champagne in the last episode she was i
cut that out though
no [ __ ] that wait a second you coming
out that you you're you're
we have abdicated too much power to
megan she cuts out her
drinking champagnes but keeps in our
champagne products right you know what
i'll cut it in right now i'll just cut
in a series of every time i drank
champagne okay great just a quick couple
of cuts
[Music]
i feel like there's one episode where
you had some cocktails and people called
you on it because they said you kept
winking i did yeah you did you actually
were oh that's funny no i well i said at
the beginning oh yeah i said at the
beginning of the newlywed game that i i
had a couple um
and i had a couple champagnes and people
in the comments were like i could tell
because she was winking and i told her
you can't i love that it's involuntary
you can't stop
i can't
you can't stop from winking this may be
transitioned to the question i had for
you guys from this episode which is um
so in the episode charlie's talking
about nose clams he's trying to use that
as a uh as a as a winky um way to say uh
cocaine
so i wanted to ask you guys have you
ever like used code had to use code to
get something like coded language or had
it used with you that you either knew at
the time or then like found out later
i mean
had to is a
like i think like
maybe in high school you know you might
have
someone there might have been like
uh
when you really used to have to like
hide weed or whatever it was you know
you maybe would have used code for that
but
no i don't think
i had i mean aside from my work at the
cia you mean aside from my home
covert operation i've been doing
we had a we had a word in grade school
that was sort of a catch-all
and it started because um we stole a
pack of uh
of
one of my friend's parents newports and
we were smoking menthol cigarettes this
is fifth grade sixth grade just to be
disgusting i don't know what we were
doing
and we were we would like smoke the
cigarettes but and then we were like
thought we were so cool and then but we
we knew we knew we couldn't call them
cigarettes or new ports when we were
talking about them so we called them
cinemax and the reason we called them
cinemax was because cinemax was a cable
channel does that even exist anymore
cinemax
i yeah i think so yeah yeah it's like
yeah maybe it is but it was a cable
channel where
um
i didn't we didn't have cable but i
would go to his house and like late at
night
cinemax would turn into skinamax and it
would be the time where you could see
like naked people on on on tv it would
show all the soft core porn stuff so
then
cinemax became this catch-all term for
anything that was whether
any kind of like paraphernalia
drug-related no i wasn't into drugs but
like even pot um
drinking alcohol uh cigarettes
nude magazines everything became cinemax
it does still exist in a max by the way
yeah that's totally what i remember it
being apparently it was like launched in
the early 80s so that's what it was
known for then
yeah soft like soft core porn yeah
i just had a memory i don't know what
made me think of this but my
my buddy aaron
lived in my neighborhood and his
neighbor
had to like
like disappear in the middle of the
night i remember this was a story there
was like there was a couple that had
been living there and they were really
shady and then they like took off and
the cops were there and
and no one's seen them right and uh so
of course as kids do we're like great
let's go sneak into their house and see
what's going on there
so
we
we snuck into the house and we were
poking around
and it was weird as [ __ ] there was like
a bunch of wigs like a bunch of like
wigs and we found like a couple like
different like ids for like the same
person
and knives and like a pack of parliament
cigarettes so we're like well let's try
one of these
awful didn't care for it you know we're
maybe too young to get hooked on that
but like just like take a puff
and then that eerie feeling of like we
should get out of here
but yeah
that's fine
you might like
how many times you might have like
crossed with someone who's like a real
life gangster and just of course you
don't know right like you have no idea
like well whitey bulger whatever his
name bulger bulger whitey bulger buddy
bulger yeah bulger was he lived and he
lived in santa monica
yeah just hanging out that area we we
run meg sometimes down say vicente he
lived in one of those apartments there
absolutely
it's crazy i wonder how many times
you've crossed path
crossed paths with someone who's
murdered someone else or like a serial
killer or something
serious killer i bet that's rare because
i think they're not rare they're not too
common i always think you know what
people say like if i got to talk to god
i would ask him like what's the or her
sorry
um where uh
don't do that um where like why do bad
things happen to good people or what's
the meaning of life and everything and i
would always ask questions like that
which is like what's the crazy like have
i ever been right next to a serial
killer or what's the closest i've ever
been to being murdered and then didn't
get murdered like things like that well
i thought about having you murdered a
couple times you know like uh i thought
it'd be funny uh then i thought it'd be
sad to be like really sad for your
friends uh then he started getting
famous and i thought well it'd be a good
story right have a good story uh and
then one day you know you were kind of
like you made a joke about me and i was
like [ __ ] you all haven't murdered uh
but mostly
i just forgot about it you know i had a
whole list of things i was dealing with
and i forgot to have you chopped up so
uh i mean
christ i mean
there's so many things you could ask god
be like why are people why how's this
part of your plan what the [ __ ] are you
doing
[ __ ]
yeah child leukemia what's that about
why you came out of little kids you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
if it's a woman it's a man it's still a
[ __ ] um
oh god i have the fear of the lightning
bolt now you know what i mean that's the
upbringing like oh i made a joke i'm
gonna get blasted
so guys
in your mind god is zeus he throws
lightning bolts then
oh most definitely where do you where
does that guy come from
uh yeah i don't know i crossed the paths
of some crazies
kids [ __ ] what else
uh
we lost we lost ray liotta
people who play gangsters
and you you charlie you've you've worked
with with ray i had the pleasure of
working with ray on my movie yet to be
released and uh
he was jazzed on it man he was i'd shown
him ed and he was really excited i think
to be in a comedy and you know
he had said
i don't know if he'd ever seen the show
but he had said he would love to have
been on sunny
so he was like why don't you have me on
your tv show sometimes like absolutely
think of something for him so oh god you
could have asked him instead of sean
penn
maybe he would have turned her at the
time now yes no time
we probably could not have cast him
either but um
well we would have tried and he would
have turned it down
that is the funny thing too i do sort of
feel like people are like yeah i'd love
to do your show and then you can't
remember we had that with sam jackson
where i feel like you and i bumped into
him or something and yeah he really like
he said he really liked the show
and then so we tried to reach out to him
for something and it's like we couldn't
even get past the walls and i'm like
don't tell me the guy won't do it the
guy answers the phone like i'm in who's
calling
that's basically
you know
what is it what are we selling credit
cards i am
[Laughter]
who is
this literally saw i i was with jason uh
bateman and his phone rang and i swear
to god as a bit but also he actually
answered it this way the phone was
ringing i said are you gonna answer that
he took it out of his pocket he goes yes
i'll do it i'll do it what is it yes
i'll do it i'll do it
[Laughter]
sam jackson man i feel like
really
you know there are certain stars that
sort of open the doors
for people to say you can do a bunch of
you can do a bunch of things and still
survive it
and he's one of them man where he was
like no i'm
[ __ ] you i'm yeah i'm gonna do the
credit card commercial and and i'm gonna
keep working with clinton or whoever you
know like
what a talent what a talent sam jackson
opening the doors charlie you're one of
those guys
you're one of those guys you're showing
showing people you can do everything
that's right i saw you and i saw you in
a green suit yeah buddy in the nba
playoffs yeah pretty sweet pay in for
the reshoots of that film
hell yeah
courtesy amounts
love it it's a funny spot what are your
favorite mobster movies guys you want to
talk about that
i mean
i mean good feelings it's hard to
hard to i could feel i think i've seen
these yeah i think i've seen good
fellows more than in any other movie
maybe because that that's a movie that's
if it's on and you're flipping through
the channels i'll just stop and watch it
no matter what
and casino's pretty great as well but
it's just amazing and the godfather and
i watch the godfather yeah i watch the
godfathers
at least once a year yeah one and two
i'll watch them at least once a year
and uh my cousin vinnie
i love that movie my cousin is great bob
analyze this i mean come on there's so
many
there's so many good ones
the sopranos right now which is also
fantastic
i know good mobster stuff
uh i haven't there's a nostalgia i have
watching
these episodes
for
the where we were as people filming them
uh you know the just seeing the mobsters
outside in the street
um
at the end of this first part episode
and that really wide shot was that fred
or was that shachman
i think this was matt chapman but i'll
look it up i think it's jacqueline i
think it might have been shaqman too
um
and just you know
just the filming in philly how fun it
was but also that like
this was everything we really didn't
have anything else going on
and i do
really miss the sort of
uh streamlined nature of that which is
that our attention was fully look
this last season of sunny we weren't
thinking about other things once we're
in we're in you know
but at the same time not only were we in
but we had everything riding on it
and i do miss that like that there's
something so and you can only do that
once you can only do that early in your
career because if it works and then
you're successful you'll never have that
thing again
of like just like the combination of
the excitement of getting the
opportunity the excitement of having
something to really prove
and then just the newness of it all the
newness of like wow we
we you know we're locking down locations
and where was it jackman who did it it
was yeah it was shackman yeah and like
this guy's pitching a shot from like
across the street and we really haven't
done something like that yet and this is
really interesting and
i love that high angle shot he has when
you do the eyes boom and then you guys
are shot from like above the whole time
you and d where you're like looking up
into the camera
i watched that again thinking that was a
mistake
thinking that that would have played
better
oh i thought that was so funny without
our faces facing the camera but that no
because of that moment not to argue with
you about your own show but because of
that moment between you and d where
you're arguing with each other about
like you saying nose clams it's more
like you're in your own world because
we're on your faces and we can't see him
as opposed to like from his perspective
which would have i agree with with that
in terms of like why it's shot that way
but i actually feel like
it moves the intent this is a weird sort
of just thing in my head but it moves
the intent too specifically to the point
of view and that that argument might
play better from
from
his point of view
where he has these two people staring up
at the sky arguing with one another as
opposed to the audience's point of view
where you get to see what they're what
they're looking for let's reshoot it
let's reshoot it
but
i think i think i remember this
conversation happening on set
i think i remember you having saying
this to
to shackman you know what's interesting
that how often that happens
yeah how often that happens where where
um even in the podcast sometimes i'll
listen back to the podcast and i'll i'll
start you'll say something and i'll
start laughing and then i hear myself in
the podcast laughing because of course i
still find the same thing
funny but i'll do the same thing with
the with the episodes where i'll feel a
certain way about how something was shot
and then i'll remember back
to the time where we were there on set
and maybe feeling the same exact way it
it it carries over a decade later you
still feel the same way even though
you're wrong
i'm probably probably wrong but it's
something that probably in the editing
room if
probably the way
we decided on that is we probably looked
at it the other way in the editing room
if we had the coverage and we said yeah
it's actually better to jump up there
because they're up they're looking up
there for so long
but it's almost like i feel like
i don't like when the camera tips the
joke in a way which is like
stay in the same coverage but just where
they're looking has changed but yeah
maybe it just would have been too much
of their chins in a wonderful like
dumpster baby when it's like from the
baby's perspective you guys were talking
about that like from the baby's pov it
was like too jokey
but i had a question actually about that
moment because like there's a whole
exchange between um charlie and dee
where
where you're you're talking about nose
clams and she's like it's confusing and
you're like it's not confusing it's like
and there's a reference to like we
discussed this was that one of those
instances where you had a scene before
that bingo scene where you guys talked
about how you were going to talk to
bingo and then you cut it almost
a hundred percent yeah
yes most likely it sounds like the kind
of scenes we write all the time and then
just get to the editing room and you're
like well something has to go and you're
like they'll the audience will know
what's happening we don't have to have a
scene saying we're gonna
we're gonna
have this argument and then i wonder if
it would be fun if we could go back we
could ask our post-production team to go
back into the archives and find some of
those scenes because most likely they
were edited and then we cut them last
minute to take some of those scenes that
we felt were unnecessary to the story
and again generally deleted scenes are
boring to watch because there's a reason
they didn't make it into the show but i
wonder if after all of this time has
passed it might be kind of a cool way to
look back
at the show and what didn't make it in
and why and kind of talk about that we
could have a whole podcast episode about
that too it could be the the cut that
cut
yeah cut that cut that cut that cut
it's like every episode's different you
know i feel like i remember
some of these earlier ones like the
molested episode or something we cut
down like under time but then under time
was the best version you know
and then some we were like oh there's no
way to
to get out you know just depending on
it's amazing how often you're watching
something and it feels
long but you look at the run time and
it's only 20 minutes and then you can
watch something else that's 40 minutes
long and it feels like you're ripping
through it because you're so engaged all
the way through
yeah in fact on this one specifically
did we
clear that it was going to be a two-part
episode with the
with the network while in the writing
process or was it something that in the
editing room we had to break up into two
episodes because we're like there's too
much content here i don't remember to
tell you the truth
i don't remember either
i know that that's happened a few times
where we broke a story that was too long
but we love the story
die was was that where we were like oh
this is too long and then we went and we
shot
more scenes yeah
we shot more scenes that's exactly what
happened
we shot more seats we had a new editor
come in tim roche who's been with us
from from that point forward and then we
realized oh all we need to do is
supplement
this second half of this story and we
can have we can have this be two two
episodes instead of one
and i believe that's when we brought the
glo the glory hall hole into it
and
i know the whole orgy storyline was part
of what was added into that for sure but
i think the glory whole thing was in
from the beginning
that was from the beginning yeah i i i
definitely remember i definitely
remember an index card
being up on the wall for a full year
that just said glory hole we we were
going to find a way to put that into an
episode
that was the scene and we're getting
ahead of ourselves but like that's the
episode where we found frank you know
what i mean where we really felt like
like frank's sort of
frank's sort of
casual attitude about the buffet at the
orgy or like okay this is the guy you
know what i mean he's a little bit more
like business
business angry business guy in these
first few seasons and then yeah just
sort of like uh interfering with my nosh
isn't that what he is sort of like
casual like a deli deli meat guy as we
became
also that whole thing with him and the
charlie like mannequin thing that he's
kind of carrying around because he
misses you so much that's sweet
yeah but the whole pimping dennis out
and this one is is great well but we
have a whole other half to talk about
yeah to get to
and as i remember it the second episode
is funnier than the first save for
the stuff with the jockey with with
buster because that scene that is one of
the best jokes
that we've done
the entire season i think is doing a
line off buster's
buzzer's boner
i kind of forgot it when we were when i
was watching it i'd sort of forgotten
that that's where it went and uh i was
very pleased and then you just like look
at him
and then you just leave
you know
yeah you know there's no um
what are you gonna think you're either
gonna do it or you're gonna leave
[Music]
you